y soy un apasionado de cancún una
fanática todo lo llevo al fanatismo y
entonces cuando agarro un tema estoy
duro y dale con la gente algunos de mis
amigos y amigos lo saben
he tocado este tema he hablado de este
tema de cancún durante los últimos seis
años sueño platico
constantemente estoy pensando maneras de
transmitir mi amor por cancún saben yo
soy pionera de esta ciudad llegué a los
10 años
de este tamaño en 1975 acabo de cumplir
40 años de haber llegado a cancún desde
antes ya veníamos mi papá mi mamá mis
hermanas así que conozco muchas
historias las historias de mis papás las
historias de los pioneros mis propias
anécdotas que comparto con amigos con
amigas que hasta la fecha de hoy
frecuentemente compartimos un cancún
selvático en cancún donde no había nada
que hacer más que era la playa
prácticamente todos los días por
supuesto ir a la escuela en donde nos
encontrábamos todo el tiempo en las
mismas actividades
donde el paraíso nos pertenecía mis
hijos nacieron aquí y es por eso que
siento
que tengo que transmitirles esto porque
cancún es la patria que me ha adoptado y
que yo también he adoptado
hace 6 años en 2009 el gobierno de la
ciudad anunció con bombo y platillo una
gran maqueta en el palacio municipal que
se iba a cambiar el palacio municipal a
una nueva ubicación es decir lo iban a
poner enfrente de la catedral las
razones que daban era que pues cancún no
tiene identidad y que había que darle
identidad poniendo nuestro palacio
municipal la nueva sede enfrente de la
catedral y también desean que con esto
nos pareceríamos a los demás pueblitos
oa las demás ciudades de méxico
yo salté como fiera porque me acuerdo
que esa noche la noche que leí la
noticia que vi en el periódico la
fotografía donde el presidente muy ufano
se asomaba a la maqueta
yo no podía dormir
porque no me imaginaba a cancún yo
llegue antes de que hubiera palacio
municipal entonces lo vi crecer y vi
construirse ese lugar
no me imaginaba cancún sin su icónico
edificio blanco junto con un grupo de
valientes ciudadanos nos lanzamos a la
defensa del palacio municipal y ahí
sigue lo logramos
el palacio sigue en pie lo que también
sigue en pie lamentablemente es la
percepción de la gente de que cancún no
tiene identidad y de que no parece
méxico saben que me ha dado cuenta a lo
largo de estos seis años de estar duro y
dale seguridad le con el mismo tema la
gente sale con que dicen es que cancún
no tiene identidad porque no lo hicieron
como una ciudad les voy a contar una
pequeña algo que recuerdo cuando estamos
con lo de la defensa del palacio
municipal un pionero porque eso no nada
más es de los que llegaron después es
también de los pioneros me dijo sabes
que estaría padre para el centro de la
ciudad
y con esto tendría identidad que le
construyeran una iglesia estilo oaxaca
estilo oaxaca o sea yo yo nada más me
quedé pensando para mis adentros por
respeto al hombre o sea se refiere a una
iglesia del siglo 16 o sea de qué
estamos hablando y es que eso no tenemos
en mente que esas ciudades bellísimas
que son coloniales que son tradicionales
mexicanas son fueron fundadas por
españoles en el siglo 16 sí es decir la
españa conquistadora sale a la conquista
del nuevo mundo para predicar el
evangelio porque era lo que ellos tenían
en mente más bien se estaba
resquebrajando los cimientos de la
iglesia católica por las protestas de
martín lutero pero esa es otra historia
entonces sale la españa conquistadora y
lo primero que hace cuando se fundan las
ciudades en el nuevo la nueva españa lo
primero que hace es poner una iglesia
encima muchas veces de centros
ceremoniales indígenas si después pone
su plaza de armas después su palacio de
gobierno su traza urbana que tenemos muy
presente que la toman también ellos de
la antigua grecia y la antigua roma y
tenemos entonces el resultado de estas
ciudades
bonitas como mérida como puebla
querétaro bellísimas nadie niega su
valor su belleza y lo
profundamente arraigados que están en
nuestra memoria como mexicanos y en el
resto del mundo también
pero cancún es otra historia cancún es
otra historia
cancún no fue fundado por españoles de
la contrarreforma del siglo 16 cancún
fue creado por mexicanos en el siglo 20
nada más les pido que hagamos así un
barrido rapidísimo por la historia e
independencia de méxico
la revolución mexicana y en medio la
separación de la iglesia del estado a
través de las reformas promovidas por
benito juárez
llegamos a la década de los 60s que nos
viene a la mente cuando cuando hablamos
de la década de los 60s
la liberación femenina
en los hippies el fin de la segregación
racial las marchas en contra de la
guerra de vietnam que ya se habían
instalado ahí los gringos en la llegada
a la luna la píldora anticonceptiva
la primavera de praga los woods tocaba
andar o todas estas cosas están pasando
cuando en 1900 están pasando en el mundo
cuando en 1967 un grupo de banqueros
mexicanos se acerca al gobierno federal
para proponer que sea a través de polos
de desarrollo turístico que se impulse
la muy amolada economía del país y se
dan a la tarea dicen porque he leído
debo sobrevolar todo el litoral mexicano
en un ds3 en un avión dc3
yo me los imagino bien sesenteros a
estos hombres
es que hay que y son y son hombres
perdón porque eran hombres son hombres y
desde durante los primeros años de
cancún se le llamó a calcula isla de los
hombres solos porque llegaron primero
los hombres vale nadie se siente
ofendido bueno entonces estos hombres
sobrevolaron todo el litoral si varias
veces buscando por lugares desde donde
desarrollar polos de desarrollo
turístico entonces había estos varios
lugares y yo me los imagino sumados por
esas ventanas y de repente viendo esta
lengua de arena que es nuestra
maravillosas nuestras maravillosas
costas nuestro cancún a partir de ahí se
dieron a la tarea de proyectar de hacer
todo el proyecto cancún en el distrito
federal
cancún no es una villa de pescadores que
haya empezado a crecer ni tampoco un
pequeño pueblo mexicano que haya se haya
empezado a desarrollar y que lo hayan
apoyado cancún es un proyecto que se
llamó desde el principio ciudad creada a
partir de cero otro nombre ciudad de
nueva creación o centro o ciudad
integralmente planeada ya teníamos
ejemplo en el mundo brasilia fue la
primera que puso el ejemplo brasil al
crear brasilia terminar la disputa entre
sao paulo y río de janeiro surge en
medio de las más zonas la capital del
país y toda esta ciudad se diseñó en los
respiradores del arquitecto oscar
niemeyer y de todo su despacho por
supuesto también en la ciudad de mexico
teníamos ese ejemplo estaba ciudad
universitaria y ciudad satélite
diseñadas por el arquitecto mario pani
los diseñadores los que hicieron el
proyecto cancún el proyecto urbanístico
fueron alumnos de mario pani entonces
están empapados de todas sus propuestas
de todas las tendencias que había en ese
entonces
así que lo primero que hacen es trazar
una ciudad totalmente diferente si
ustedes tuvieron la oportunidad de
fundar una nueva ciudad se irían siglos
atrás lo que más quisiéramos es
implementar la vanguardia a nuestros
propios pensamientos y de lo que estamos
empapados a nuestro alrededor
entonces
fundan bueno digamos crean esta ciudad a
partir de cero de los fundadores vienen
después y se vienen aquí a cancún a
ejecutar el proyecto traza en esta
ciudad a base de supermanzanas que son
un concepto de mario pani inspirado en
las células urbanas por eso nos resulta
un poquito difícil a los que vienen de
otras provincias dicen que es esto
porque supermanzanas porque tenemos
porque no hay colonias ya les dije
porque no hay colores porque no venimos
de la colonia sostenemos supermanzanas
pero no
tenemos supermanzanas en vez de colonias
tenemos retornos en vez de calles
tenemos glorietas para facilitar la
circulación porque se suponía que nunca
iba a haber un semáforo en cancún
aparecieron hasta en 1990 y si
supiéramos usar las glorietas no
tendríamos que usar los semáforos por
supuesto pero bueno
entonces también lo que hacen es poner
un palacio municipal ese que defendimos
a capa y espada
y ponen una hermosa plaza de la reforma
de la reforma y hay un monumento de
benito juárez que nos recuerda que
nuestro municipio es un canto a la
libertad de culto no hay ninguna iglesia
enfrente no existe el pensamiento
religioso porque ya no había necesidad
mi intención un poquito al hablar de
esto es que dejemos abandonemos esta
esta añoranza que tenemos como si fuera
lo único mexicano estos mexicanos del
siglo 20 de la década de los 60
reflejaron también los tiempos por los
que había pasado el mismo país
sostenemos esta hermosa plaza de la
reforma y si alguien quiere ir a la
iglesia está del otro lado la iglesia
católica y equidistante está la
presbiteriana ese es un canto la
libertad de culto en nuestra ciudad una
ciudad que nace laica desde sus inicios
por eso pegamos el grito en el cielo
cuando la querían cambiar en frente de
la catedral
otra cosa que aporta a la identidad de
cancún la multiculturalidad cancún nace
como una ciudad turística desde sus
inicios esto llamó a visitantes de
prácticamente todas partes del mundo
también vinieron los servidores
turísticos los trabajadores de la
construcción y los empresarios y todo
esto conformado una amalgama fascinante
divertida multicolor variopinta de
culturas y de nacionalidades el
instituto nacional de inmigración
registró en 2009 que había más de 100
nacionalidades en cancún viviendo entre
102 y 115 oscilan también los 32 estados
de la república están representados en
cancún quieres comer cabrito lo
encuentras también estás ajo también te
ayudas cochinita pero también te
encuentras con que hay sushi y comida
beliceña y comida los los venezolanos
arman un merequetengue y también los
colombianos celebran su independencia y
los chilenos aquí en cancún se imaginan
a los neoyorquinos lamentándose porque
no tenemos identidad porque
y tantas partes del mundo
estoy imaginar
esta es una ciudad única los que vivimos
acá la hemos construido entre todos en
cancún no se derramó una sola gota de
sangre tenemos un escudo no tenemos un
gran fervor funk tenemos un no tenemos
un escudo pero no tenemos un escudo de
armas tenemos un logotipo lo diseñó un
diseñador comercial guard diseñador
gráfico o artista comercial como le
decían en ese entonces curiosamente el
diseñador de nuestro logotipo del
ayuntamiento también hizo el póster de
avándaro para que vean en qué estaban
metidos estos hombres el póster del
concierto de la banda vale entonces esto
es nuestro cancún si tenemos ahí hay un
monumento bellísimo en medio de la
ciudad para mí uno de los más bellos que
es en honor a josé martí
y en él hay un fragmento que dice yo
vengo de todas partes y hacia todas
partes voy yo creo que eso define lo que
somos los cancunenses por lo menos me
define a mí nací en bruselas bélgica mi
papá es italiano mi madre era mexicana
pues ahora sí que de donde soy soy
cancunense lo puedo decir al igual que
mis hijos que nacieron aquí al igual que
los hijos de ustedes en cancún los
héroes si es que pudiéramos hacer un
monumento para nuestros héroes primero
yo pondría a los creadores del proyecto
cancún esos hombres visionarios que se
atrevieron a soñar esta ciudad pondría a
los hombres y mujeres que han llegado de
todas partes del mundo desde el inicio
los pioneros los fundadores que como mis
papás se les tuvieron que ver bastante
difícil si todo estaba muy bonito pero
no había nada muy difícil vivir en
cancún también pondría a nuestros hijos
sus hijos nuestras hijas que han nacido
aquí en cancún y que conforman parte de
este censo sólido cancunense pero
también pondría a la familia que llegó
la semana pasada a la pareja que acaba
de llegar ayer ya los que están
desempacando en el crucero que vienen de
guatemala o que vienen de nicaragua con
los mismos sueños que llegaron
que por cierto se nos están muriendo
nuestros pioneros y prácticamente no hay
nadie que esté haciendo un registro de
ellos y ahí con ellos se están yendo sus
casas los edificios y la traza urbana
también yo les pido mi sueño el estar
aquí para compartir esto la próxima vez
que ustedes se encuentren en una
conversación en donde salga este estas
cosas de todo lo que le falta cancún de
todo lo que no tiene cancún se acuerden
de hoy y digan sabes que yo ahora sé que
cancún tiene identidad
que cancún tiene historia y que cancún
también es méxico muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
gracias
todas las gracias
[Aplausos]